poupou à chatou le célèbre coureur
cycliste français des années 60 70
raymond poulidor est venu dédicacer ses
livres à la fois international à la
brocante la possibilité pour lui de
rencontrer ses fans ont retracé
évidemment un semblant parole l'ensemble
de ma carrière et la conversation
revient souvent avec jacques anquetil
qui est toujours présent ce fameux duel
avec jacques anquetil est toujours
imposant question comment se fait-il
vous n'avez pas gagné plusieurs pour de
france c'était ses meilleurs adversaires
jacques anquetil dans les années 60 et
eddy merckx dans les années 70
raymond poulidor avait cette image
d'éternel second mais cette exposition
consacrée à sa carrière mais aussi en
lumière de nombreuses victoires sur le
plus populaire c'est pas c'est pas
l'éternel seront pas s'il a gagné 157
course sur le bas c'est là une légende
mais c'est un peu le mythe d'un grand
coureur mais qui n'a pas réussi toujours
faire ce qu'il voulait c'est un
personnage
un gars courageux qui a pas eu toujours
de ma chance dans ces courses cyclistes
bon j'ai entendu à la télé et qui disait
qu'il était toujours 2e mais non parce
qu'il a quand même gagné pas mal de
choses de milan san remo tour d'espagne
trophée maillot vélo tous les trésors de
poulidor sont à retrouver durant cette
exposition prévue jusqu'au 24 mars à la
foire de chatou